it's the first time we've heard in
detail from the man at the center
of this scandal speaking to the sunday
times martin beshear can't bring himself
to admit
he was wrong i never wanted to harm
diana in any way
and i don't believe we did he says
everything we did
in terms of the interview was as she
wanted from when she wanted to alert the
palace
to when it was broadcast to its contents
my family and i loved her in many ways
his comments will only fuel the demand
for answers from the bbc
and others who were involved like former
director general
lord hall whose investigations into
martin beshear and the fake documents
were described
as woeful after calls for him to step
back from public life
he's resigned as chair of the national
gallery
chris blackhurst was one of the
journalists that the bbc
lied to after he asked if beshear had
told diana she was being spied on
there's no way that lord hall could have
carried on as chairman because i
think i'm right in saying that the
prince of wales is patron
of the national gallery and that would
really really be compromising for him
and whatever he did as chairman of the
gallery every time he did anything or
the gallery did anything
questions about martin bashir and the
princess of wales would always be asked
so it was impossible
but hall's apology doesn't go far enough
for those who believe this has raised
serious questions
about how the bbc is governed no one is
bigger than the organization
and the need to ensure that when they do
actually
uh when they do actually put things
forward the editorial policy unit
actually has
a real say and real clout so that it's
with halt with stands or
sorry withholds the um uh the standards
that you'd expect of our leading public
service broadcaster
some who worked at the most senior
levels within the corporation
agree this is a time to look inward
there was a systemic failure as well as
an individual failure
and correcting that is important for the
individuals for the staff involved
involved in the bbc
but it's of course terribly important
for the audience and the license repair
for diana's brother lord spencer it's
the met
police he now wants to act we understand
he's
again written to the force demanding
they look further into the fake bank
statements
used by bashir to deceive him he also
alleges diana was a victim of blackmail
and fraud it has brought back
painful memories for diana's family
prince william
representing the queen as lord high
commissioner of the church of scotland
unexpectedly spoke about the difficult
days around diana's death
i was in balmoral when i was told that
my mother had died
still in shock i found sanctuary in the
service at crafty kirk that very morning
and in the dark days of grief that
followed i found comfort and solace
in the scottish outdoors i'm told that
prince william is going to continue
working with the bbc
on certain projects but he has made it
very clear
that he never wants that interview with
his mother to be shown again
and in some way he wants the bbc to try
and correct that false narrative
that he says it portrayed for so many
years
the interview sparked a chain of events
that rocked the monarchy the queen again
out on public duties visiting hms queen
elizabeth has of course in recent years
weathered other difficulties this time
her family and her institution are not
under attack but through painful
memories
are still feeling the repercussions
rhiannon mills
sky news in edinburgh